just when you thought friday couldn't
get any better
amazon have just announced that there's
going to be a spin-off show set in the
boys universe
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about it
but if you're new to the channel then
please smash that subscribe button like
it's someone's head
that you've just happened to apprehend
in a back alley now as always
this is their v spoiler show i'm your
host paul now let's get into the
breakdown
okay so i think it's safe to say that
season two of the show has been a pretty
big success
and it seems to be one of the only good
things to come out of 2020
though a lot of people were disappointed
with the weekly release schedule
i think it's kept everyone talking about
the series and the boys currently stands
as one of amazon's most successful
shows ever the second entry has in fact
more than doubled the season one
viewership worldwide
and overall it's had an 89 increase in
audience
clearly amazon know when they've got
something good going and yesterday
deadline exclusively dropped a report
that stated there was a second season in
development at the streaming service
this was further backed up by seth rogen
who retweeted it
explaining that the vote cinematic
universe was expanding
wait who's that at the bottom goose
wayne
no no give this guy just give this guy a
job he deserves it
anyway deadline actually dropped some
info on what we can expect to see in the
show
and we'll actually follow a group of
teenage superheroes that attend a
college
run by war international the upcoming ra
it series will follow some students as
they get to grips with their hormones
and tackle all kinds of things like
their sexual
physical and moral boundaries the heroes
are going to be competing for some of
the best contracts in the city
and they'll be pitted against each other
as they try to join some of the
superhero teams that exist in the
universe
if you're a fan of the comic then you'll
know that there are a lot of teams such
as payback
and teenage kicks the latter of which i
can actually see being included in the
show
in the comics kicks were one of the
lesser superhero teams
that were under contract by vote they're
sort of the teen titans of the world
that were created in order to allow the
corporation to market their products to
a rebellious teenage crowd
this would normally make for a pretty
fun team but if you've read the source
material
you'll know there's some of the most
depraved characters in the entire comic
i don't even want to talk about what one
of them does with a hamster
now if you haven't read the books yet
then i recommend that you pick up volume
1
as this actually centers around huey's
first mission which involves spying on
the kicks
and here we learn about the messed up
stuff that they get into as for the new
series
it's been described as park college show
part hunger games
apparently satirizing both the pilot is
currently being written by craig
rosenberg
who will also serve as an executive
producer and showrunner for the series
on top of this eric kripke is also going
to be involved
alongside rogan kripke is the main
developer behind the tv show
and his name pretty much always appears
at the start of the credits
so you know it's in good hands i think
this show will open the door for a lot
of different cameos and appearances
and as we know starlight was in a
similar situation to the students at the
college before she was enrolled in the
seven
they have a lot of opportunities here
and i actually love it if we got some
prequel elements in it because a
who doesn't want to learn more about
what homelander was like as a teenager
another thing that they could
potentially do with this season is give
the backstory to new characters
so we get a fully fleshed out origin
story for them before they join the
seven
in the comics there's a lot of team
members that get killed
and then replaced and i think this would
be a brilliant opportunity to introduce
new characters that could jump across to
the main series
in my opinion it's a really smart move
by amazon to start building this
quote-unquote cinematic universe
and it'll no doubt add a lot of
opportunities to to take the mick out of
every company in hollywood
who at one point were trying to build
their own anyway i'll of course keep you
updated on all the news as we get it
but in the meantime drop your comments
below on what you want to see in the
series
and if you're enjoying the new run or
not now if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of episode 6
which is going to be linked at the end
we go over all the easter eggs
and give our theories on what's gonna
happen next so it's definitely worth
checking out after this
don't forget we're also giving away a
free copy of the christopher nolan
collection
and all you have to do to be when the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of september so make sure
you get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat who's on a
discord server linked in the description
or heavyspoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you been the best i've been definition
and i'll see you next time
take care peace
to say